-Take the love, a standing O
for Edward Norton.
Come on, bud. Welcome back.
I missed having you on the show.
-I know. It's great,
great to be back.
I feel like
we're back alive again.
-Yeah, it feels right.
Everyone, we got crowds.
We have audiences
in the building.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We just had puppies predict
March Madness.
And I thought since, staying
with the basketball theme,
I was going to talk to you
a little bit about basketball.
And then I was doing --
I remembered
that you dunked famously
in the movies,
in "American History X."
This is you.
This is you dunking the ball.
You. Not many people can say
they dunked on film before,
but you have.
Do you remember
getting air on this?
-There's a lot to say about
this.
[ Laughter ]
I was very pumped up on,
you know, for that film.
-You were jacked.
-And everybody thought
that equated to vertical
jumping capability, right?
So we get out there
to shoot it.
They're going to do
these special shots
to get the dunk.
-Where are you filming it?
-In the Venice basketball
courts. Right?
So there's a lot
of real players all around
and everything like that.
And they say, "Where
do you want us to set the rim?"
And I said, "I don't know.
You know, nine feet.
Nine feet. That should be good,
right?"
-Yeah, that's my dude!
That's Edward Norton.
-No, it didn't go well.
It didn't go well.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I was prison body on top
and like legs of a of a Kenyan
marathon runner on the bottom.
They put me in sweatpants
to hide the differential
between up here and down here.
So I missed.
So I'm like -- I'm banging the
ball up against the underside
at nine feet.
-You're dunking up.
-So then the worst
possible thing,
which is they have to lower it
in front of everybody, right?
So I'm already
catching [bleep]
They lower it
and it's still not enough.
And I'm getting more and more
tired. At the end of the day,
basically, I put my hand
as high as I could reach.
They put the rim at my wrist...
[ Laughter ]
And basically my --
-This is like a Nerf hoop on the
back of a closet somewhere
in a bedroom.
-I'm standing
on the ground in that shot.
[ Laughter ]
That is the honest --
-Movie magic.
-And actually I'm getting
embarrassed
at the memory
of the catcalls.
-Sorry. Sorry.
-So can we go to something...
-Yes, of course we can. Yes, we
can go right to the next.
-...I did well in a film?
-Let's talk about "Glass Onion,"
by the way,
because that was gigantic.
You were great.
You were fantastic in that.
When we first meet
your character, Miles,
Miles Bron,
you're playing guitar,
and I know
you play some guitar,
but you were playing
"Blackbird" pretty well.
I was like,
"Is that really you?"
Or did you lower the rim
on this one?
[ Laughter ]
-No. So that --
Like you,
I'm an amateur guitar player.
I can play "Blackbird."
And I think maybe
that's why I got the part,
because he was supposed
to be playing
"Blackbird"
specifically at that point.
And Rian Johnson,
the director, said,
"Can you play it?"
I said, "Actually, I can."
So I -- So yes,
I was playing it in that.
The thing is, though,
I don't -- You sit in
sometimes, right?
Like, you -- I remember you
at the "Saturday Night Live"
40th party.
You were sitting in.
But I think if you play guitar
a little, you know,
I have these dreams
like where Springsteen
has called me on stage
and I'm failing.
Do you have guitar-fail dreams?
-Oh, my gosh. I have just
nothing but fail dreams.
[ Laughter ]
Made a career out of it.
That's why I'm a comedian.
-But the funny thing --
and the funny thing on that one
was because there's this --
Enough people
have seen the movie.
I don't think it ruins it
that my character
is kind of revealed
to be a pretentious idiot.
-Yeah.
-Right?
But we -- I had this --
You're a Beatles aficionado.
I really wanted that --
She comes up and she says,
"You're playing my song."
And he says, yeah, on the guitar
he wrote it on.
And it's supposed to be like
he actually bought things.
And I said to Rian, "What if --
Can I say, like, on the guitar
John wrote it on"
because McCartney wrote it,
and this would be good
because like --
-Inside.
-Yeah, inside baseball
but another level on which
he's an idiot, right?
I thought it'd be great.
And basically Rian was like,
"I'm not getting into
the McCartney-Lennon
authorship wars."
He's like, "No."
And I said, "Paul will get it.
Paul is cool."
-Yeah. He's like, "No."
By the way, the fact that Paul
said yes to even letting
"Glass Onion" be used,
I'm like,
dude, that was just --
it was masterful.
That's hilarious.
You tried to get nerdy.
-I thought it would be a good
joke to attribute
"Blackbird" to John Lennon.
-I found a photo that I wanted
to show you
that I think this is
actually -- you set it up
perfectly without even knowing
I'm going to show you this,
but this is a photo of you from
I think this was 2001.
Here's Paul McCartney
playing guitar,
Eric Clapton behind him.
And in between, a very...
[ Laughter ]
Are you having a nightmare?
That's two of the
greatest guitarists.
-Where do you even find that?
-Dude, do you remember?
-Well, it's an incredibly
weird picture
because it looks like
I'm trying to tune
Clapton's guitar
while he's playing it.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "You're a little
flat. You're a little flat."
-"Mr. Eric, come here.
I'll help you with that."
-But also, I'm sitting here
thinking, like,
did I have such a hit movie that
I felt I belonged on this stage?
-Yes, you do!
-With Clapton and things.
Like, what is going on?
-I've seen you play
with Eddie Vedder.
Was that --
I saw you somewhere.
-I sat in once
with Eddie Vedder.
-So you know
what you're talking about.
-No, no. It was the
most nerve-wracking performance
experience of my life
because he said,
"Why don't you just sit in
for one song?" So I said,
Let's play 'Guaranteed.'"
This was at the Beacon.
This was at our hometown
theater here, right?
-Yeah. New York.
-I'm like, "Let's play
'Guaranteed.'"
I know "Guaranteed" pretty well,
right?
Right before we go out
and do it --
and his fans
are intense, man --
You don't mess with
like the Eddie --
I was like, "I could get booed."
-Oh, yeah.
-I go out, right?
I'm like, "Okay, I can play
'Guaranteed' well enough
that this will go fine."
And then he's like --
right before he goes,
"Take a verse, take a verse."
I'm like,
"I'm not singing with you."
-No! I'm barely doing this.
-He's like, "Take a verse.
Take a verse."
And Eddie's voice
sounds like it's rising
from the mantle of the Earth.
You know, it's like
this huge thing.
And I opened my mouth and
it's like Bob Dylan
and Ellie Goulding have had
a had a baby, right?
It's just a disaster.
It's like you don't want to
sing next to Eddie Vedder.
-You just want
to tune his guitar.
That's all you want to do.
-Exactly.
So it's just like you
got to be very careful
about sitting in
with the pros.
-"Extrapolations."
We have to talk about
your show "Extrapolations."
The cast, by the way, is --
Yeah, the show is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's on Apple TV+.
The cast.
I'm just going to run through
some names here.
No order. Sienna Miller.
Kit Harington.
David Schwimmer. Daveed Diggs.
Tobey Maguire. Forest Whitaker.
Murray Bartlett.
Meryl Streep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Marion Cotillard.
-Yeah. They said Meryl Streep,
Marion Cotillard.
I was like, "I don't care what
it's about."
-"I'm in."
-Right.
And then I didn't get to work
with either of them.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You were saying this.
-It's like an all star --
I think a way to look
at this is,
is it's sort of like the --
if you like "Black Mirror,"
you know, the way that "Black
Mirror" comments on technology,
which I was obsessed
with that show.
This is very much
like a "Black Mirror"
for future environmental
kind of consequence
and catastrophe.
It's really, really creative.
It's rooted in science, but
it's -- Some of them are funny.
Some of them
are really dramatic
and kind of terrifying
and dystopian.
And it just -- I think that
it's entertaining as hell,
But it's a really
great provocation
to get us to think
about what might actually
be coming
on an environmental level,
not just a technological level.
-Since I've known you,
you've always been
active in the environment,
saving the environment
and, you know,
watching out for climate change
and all this stuff.
-Yeah, honestly, it's
nice when the thing you do --
when you have the opportunity
to wrestle
with some of those complicated
questions and challenges
that we're facing
within the work.
I mean, I think --
-It's still entertaining.
-Yeah, it is entertaining.
It's very entertaining,
but it's not preachy.
It really basically
deals with how difficult
this is going to be to make
these complicated decisions.
-And how life is going
to be in the future.
It starts in when, 2037?
-Yeah. And it advances
through time as the episodes go.
But I think, you know,
look, we live in a very --
we live in an age of distraction
and of a lot --
There's a lot of challenges
to life.
And I think
the most it asks of people
is really that, you know,
this is --
this is going to be
the challenge of our era.
I think we will be
remembered mostly
for how we deal with this issue
of ecological sustainability
and whether we
set things in motion
that future generations
are dealing with.
And I think all this
really asks you to do is --
is not be complacent,
you know, to at least meditate
on the consequences
of these decisions
that we're making right now
and think a little bit about
what it's actually going to
look like if we don't act.
[ Applause ]
-What would you say
for someone
who wants to get
get involved or --
-You know, again, it's hard
to -- I mean, in the old days,
like, I think we liked
hearing things that,
you know, changing light bulbs
and this and that.
But we know that
that's not -- those things
aren't really what it's about.
It's about policy.
It's about governments.
And that's why
a lot of people feel
that it's beyond
their capability.
I think we've got to vote.
We've got to bring
in a generation of leaders
who put this -- who believe
that this is a priority
and make it a priority.
But also, I just think,
you know,
I think of -- There's a line
of Hemingway's
that's cited in the episode
I'm in that the world
is a fine place
and worth fighting for.
And I think that we've
got to push against complacency.
I think we can afford
as a generation and our kids,
we can't be complacent
about this.
It's too consequential.
-Yeah. Good for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well said.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Edward Norton
in "Extrapolations."
Take a look at this.
-The real reckless experiment
is the one civilization
has been running.
-Nobody was trying
to change the climate.
We didn't even think
that we had that capacity.
We didn't know better.
But we do now.
-And yet human behavior
doesn't change.
The sky is easier to re-engineer
than the human brain, John.
-Exactly.
And if you tell
that greedy monkey brain,
it's cooled off
and everything's okay,
it's going to say,
"Give me a little bit more.
Just let me burn
a little bit more.
Just let me -- Just let me
mortgage a little more
of the children's future
so that I can make sure
I can choose
this quarterly balance sheet.
I just need that one."
It's -- It's -- It's --
Gita, Gita.
Even if you got all of the
chemical interactions right,
if you got the
dispersal pattern right,
the problem here is bigger
than the heat of the sun, Gita.
It's the way we see the world.
-Edward Norton, everybody!
"Extrapolations"
is streaming now
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with Ego Nwodim.
Stick around, everybody.